you don't really care about his motives
whether he loves or he hates you that
took 6 hours to to to get into that and
I was like oh man I couldn't sit still
for 6 hours I really couldn't and then I
remember we're on 5 hours and then
someone came in went we shut production
now and it was Co I was I was like huh
really what what happened there was like
the steel thing like G that was like
slicing in I I'm really going to be left
with a scar here so I was like that and
was in the B suit and I'm like ha and
he's like ha I'm like no ha you we
couldn't move we literally couldn't get
up and move I was looking at pictures of
asylums and I remember seeing this thing
on the in this Asylum picture and I
always saved on my phone and around the
Batman like the Joker it said spray
paint of an old assoil room and I said
hell was more fun I was like w like that
is
crazy